it looks more like a war zone than a
street protest Bolivia's political
unrest turned deadly on Friday as
supporters of former President Evo
Morales clashed with police in the town
of sakaba as the dead were buried
emotions were raw and anger directed at
Bolivia's self-appointed president
Janina and yes so this is what they call
democracy killing us like we are nothing
they are not numbers they are lives
where is the justice
morales supporters have been taking to
the streets since he resigned and fled
the country to Mexico earlier this week
claiming a coup had taken place these
protests against the four-day-old
government led by conservative and yes
are a stark indication of the political
upheaval taking place and yes has
dismissed Morales his allegations of a
coup No Mas mani bulid or if the most
manipulative thing that former president
Morales is doing now is to convince the
international community that it was a
coup when the coup has been against
Bolivians on many occasions and would
you help or who need re onions again
drew attention to accusations of
election irregularities and government
corruption under Morales officials say
that violence civil unrest has claimed
more than 19 lives since October the
country's Ombudsman has called for a
government investigation into the use of
force by the security forces police
however lay the blame firmly at the
protesters feet this is not a peaceful
movement that needs to be made very
clear because the protesters can't claim
that they come in peace when we
intervene we find these sorts of things
while force is used to disperse the
crowds further casualties seem an
inevitability before stability returns
[Music]